this is someone that the right was going
to as an authority on covid earlier in
the pandemic listen to this i saw people
walking on the street and some were
human and some were over so we're demons
and the human beings didn't realize that
they were walking around with demons so
right now we are in a time where i would
actually say people have been cloned and
they are walking among us if you watch
the movie called they leave
they live live
it was created by john papenter this is
the world we live in right now and the
only way we're gonna survive is if human
beings wake up stop all the crazy
factions the devil has put us in and
start praying and crying out to god
because that is the only way we're gonna
we're gonna suffer now often with these
folks i come to you and i say
this is not a medical doctor
the crazy thing is
stella emmanuel is a medical doctor she
is
as far as i know she is a physician and
a pastor
and she was pushing hydroxychloroquine
absent any evidence